hi Ted bellacor with reason TV recently
in Park City Utah I had the pleasure of
chatting with independent film legend
Lloyd Kaufman greetings from trouble
girl my phone call president of Troma
entertainment and creator of the toxic
avenger Troma entertainment is the
herpes of the film industry we will not
go away Troma entertainment the oldest
independent movie studio probably the
longest running independent studio with
35 years under our cardboard belt but we
are definitely the longest-running
independent movie studio that has never
had a hit we had one in kind of a hit
single called the toxic avenger New
Jersey's first superhero hideously
deformed creature with superhuman size
and strength who is endowed with an
ability to jump and he's got him up the
South Park guys Trey Parker and Matt
stones first movie was cannibal the
musical which nobody wanted and then we
distributed it I think we helped him
finish it and then South Park came about
and actually tray and Matt are the ones
who inspired the Troma dance film
festival they wanted to submit their
movie to the Sundance Film Festival and
of course they didn't even get a [ __ ]
you letter back from Sundance so they
came out here and had their one movie
film festival cannibal the musical film
festival huge hit and and then that kind
of led to trauma dance because a tray
tray said we should maybe call it trauma
because everybody hates stroma
drama dance film festival that the main
thing is that it's a genuinely
independent film festival and it gives
truly independent filmmakers it gives a
venue for the movies made for the vibe I
love of filmmaking not by trying to put
packages together or trying to figure
out what Harvey Weinstein wants
Shakespeare was a [ __ ] disturber and I
don't think that the Sundance of
Elizabethan age accepted Winter's Tale
in their festival back in the 1600s a a
lot of his plays had to play beyond the
walls of London and sometimes
Shakespeare had to play old play with
himself about 200 companies or members
of independent film and television
alliance and the board of the
independent film and television alliance
has voted unanimously to hire two to
spend a lot of money lobbying in
Washington to try to educate that the
Congress and the FCC that that
independent art is under assault and not
just under assault but independent art
is also under a pepper if our country is
to continue to have the innovation of
independent movie studios we cannot
allow a small number of
devil-worshipping international media
conglomerates to control everything we
see read and and here
my latest book is direct your own damn
movie and talks about how I've directed
my own damn movies and how to do it my
way and also there are interviews with
many of the directors who have come out
of the Troma the Troma age James Gunn
who directed seizure and wrote
scooby-doo and we wrote Romeo and Juliet
together Eli Roth who went on to make
cabin fever and hostile and he's hot hot
hot and the South Park guys I
interviewed tray and Matt so there are a
lot of side bars with successful
directors Penelope Spheeris of course
Penelope Spheeris talks not only about
the comedy and how to stay independent
and do it how to be able to get movies
done that that you truly believe in but
also about the the situation of being a
guy no American director I don't know
why there aren't more guy no American
directors I imagine it's just that there
is an elite cabal that controls our
industry you see every movie I've
written and directed from the toxic
avenger to class of nuke em high to
Romeo and Juliet terror firmer poultry
guys night of the chicken dead the basic
premise is that there was a small town
of Tromaville and the conspiracy of
elites the labor elite the the labor
leaders who are making millions of
dollars while their rank and file or
eating dog food the the bureaucratic
elite namely the Congress and then the
corporate elite
it's a yin and a yang I majored in
Chinese Studies at Yale and Taoism was
one of the thing I came out with the
problem is you you you unless you are in
with the monopoly or the Oleg opoly you
cannot penetrate the hymen of the
mainstream unless you get [ __ ] so it's
very very hard for the independent
filmmaker to get his or her art to the
public the good news however is that
there is there is a tsunami of digital
aged movies now that the the
democratization of cinema has come on
full strength anyone can make a movie
when I made battle loves return in 1970
that's the one that Oliver Stone was in
it was 16-millimeter movie played in
movie theaters cost eight thousand
dollars in nineteen seventy eight
thousand dollars probably today eight
thousand dollars of 1970 would be a
couple hundred thousand and still a
shitload of money poltergeist is five
hundred thousand dollars poultry guys
distill even though that's a tiny tiny
budget compared to the PAP that is on
your local movie screen but it's still a
huge amount you can start a lot of dress
shops for five hundred thousand dollars
but now with a democrat the
democratization of filmmaking everyone
can make movies it's great